Now you will learn about the three Ms in statistics:
the mean, the median, and the mode.
And these are terms that are really important to know.
They are useful in looking at data, and they are often confused.
So let me bring clarity to the story of the three Ms.
Let's talk about the first.
We talked quite a bit about house prices,
and here is a list of possible house prices.
The mean is using the exact same formula as in the previous unit.
It's the average of all those prices over here.
Do me a favor and quickly compute it for those numbers over here.
When you put in the number, don't worry about the thousands.
It's something between 165 and 190.